This lecture is about the query
likelihood probabilistic retrieval
model.
In this lecture we continue the
discussion of probabilistic retrieval
model.
In particular, we're going to talk
about the query likelihood retrieval
function.
In the query likelihood retrieval
model.
Our idea is to model how likely a user
who likes a document would pose a
particular query.
So in this case you can imagine if a
user likes this particular document
about the presidential campaign news.
Then we can assume the user would use
this document as a basis to post a
query to try to retrieve this document.
So we can imagine the user could use a
process.
That works as follows, where we assume
that the query is generated by sampling
words from the document.
So for example, a user might pick a word
like presidential from this document.
And then use this as a query word.
And then the user would pick another
word like "campaign" and that will be
the second query word.
Now this of course is assumption that
we have made about how a user would
pose a query.
Whether user actually followed this
process.
Maybe a different question, but this
assumption has allowed us to formulate
characterize this conditional
probability.
And this allows us to also not rely on
the big table that I showed you earlier
to use empirical data to estimate this
probability.
And this is why we can use this idea to
them.
Further derive retrieval function that
we can implement with the program
language.
So as you see, the assumption that
we've made here is each query word is
independently sampled and also each
word is basically obtained from the
document.
So now let's see how this works
exactly.
Well, since we are computing the query
likelihood.
Then the probability here is just the
probability of this particular query,
which is a sequence of words.
And we make the assumption that each
word is generated independently, so as
a result, the probability of the query
is just a product of the probability of
each query word.
Now, how do we compute the probability
of each query word
Well based on the assumption that a word
is picked from the document.
That the user has in mind. Now we know the
probability of each word is just to
the relative frequency of the word in
the document.
So for example, the probability of
presidential given the document.
Would be just the count of presidential
in the document divided by the total
number of words in the document or
document length.
So with this these assumptions, we now
have actually simple formula for
retrieval, right?
We can use this to rank our documents.
So does this model work?
Let's take a look.
Here are some example documents that
you have seen before.
Suppose now the query is presidential
campaign and we see the formula here on
the top.
So how do we score these documents?
It's very simple, right?
We just count how many times we have
seen "presidential" or how many times we
have seen campaign et cetera and within
here for d4 and we have seen presidential
twice that's two over the length
of Document 4 multiplied by 1 over length of
document 4 for probability of campaign.
And similarly we can get probabilities
for the other two documents.
Now if you look at this, these numbers
or these formulas for scoring all these
documents.
It seems to make sense be cause if we
assume D3 and D4 have about the
same length than looks like we're going to
rank D4 above D3, and
which is above D2 as we would expect,
looks like it did capture the TF
heuristic.
And so this seems to work well.
However.
If we try a different query like this
one presidential campaign update.
Then we might see a problem.
What problem?
Well think about the update now.
None of these documents has mentioned
update.
So according to our assumption that a
user would pick a word from a document
to generate a query, then the
probability of obtaining a word like
update.
Would be what? Would be 0, right?
So that caused a problem because
we cause all these documents to have zero
probability of generating this query.
Now, while it's fine to have zero
probability for D2 which is non
relevant, it's not OK to have zero for
D3 and D4, because now we
no longer can distinguish them.
What's worse, we can't even distinguish
them from D2, right?
So that's obviously not desirable.
Now, whenever we've had such result.
We should think about what has caused
this problem.
So we have to examine what assumptions
have been made.
As we derive this ranking function.
Now, if you examine those assumptions
carefully, you would realize what has
caused this problem.
Right?
So take a moment to think about what do
you think is the reason why update has
zero probability.
And how do we fix it?
Right, so if you think about this for a
moment, you realize that that's because
we have made assumption that every
query word must be drawn from the
document in the user's mind.
So in order to fix this, we have to
assume that
the user could have drawn a word not
necessarily from the document, so let's
improve the model and the improvement
here is to say that instead of drawing
a word from the document, let's imagine
that the user would actually draw a
word from a document model.
So I showed model here.
We assume that this document is
generated using this unigram language
model.
Now this model.
Doesn't necessarily assign zero
probability for update.
In fact that we consume this model does
not assign zero probability for any
word.
Now if we think in this way,
then the generation process is a little
bit different.
Now the user has this model in mind.
Instead of this particular document.
Although the model has to be estimated
based on the document.
So the user can again generate the
query using a similar process, namely
pick a word. For example, presidential.
And another word, campaign.
Now the difference is that this time we
can also pick a word like update even
though update does not occur in the
document to potentially generate the
query word like update so that
a query with update want to have zero
probabilities.
So this will fix our problem, and it's
also reasonable because we're now
thinking of what the user is looking
for in a more general way.
That is unigram language model instead
of a fixed document.
So how do we compute this query
likelihood?
If we make this assumption?
Well, it involves 2 steps, right?
The first is to compute this model.
And we call it the document language
model here.
For example, I've shown two
possible language models here is made
based on two documents.
And then given a query and I get
data mining algorithms.
The second step would just compute
the likelihood of this query and by
making independent assumptions we
could then have this probability as a
product of the probability of each
query word.
But we do this for both documents and
then we're going to score these two
documents and then rank them.
So that's the basic idea of this query,
likelihood retrieval function.
So more generally then, this ranking
function would look like the following
right here we assume that the query has
N words.
W one through WN, and then the scoring
function.
The ranking function is.
Probability that we observe this query
given that the user is thinking of this
document.
And this is assumed to be product of
probabilities of all individual words.
This is based on the independence
assumption.
Now we actually often score the
document for this query by using log of
the query likelihood as shown on the
second line.
Now we do this.
To avoid having a lot of small
probabilities.
We multiply together and this could
cause underflow and we might lose
precision by transforming the value with
a logarithm function.
We maintain the order of these
documents, yet we can avoid the
underflow problem.
So if we take logarithm transformation,
of course the product that would become
a sum as shown on the second line here.
So it's a sum over all the query words
inside the sum.
The value is log of the probability of
this word given by the document.
And then we can further rewrite the sum
into a different form.
So in the first sum here.
In this sum,
We have it all over the query words N
query words.
And in this sum we have a sum over all
the possible words, but we put a count
here of each word in the query.
Essentially we are only considering the
words in the query because if a word is
not in the query, the count would be
0.
So we're still considering only these N
words.
But we are using a different form, as
if we're going to take sum over all
the words in the vocabulary.
And of course, a word might occur
multiple times in the query.
That's why we have a count here.
And then this part is log of the
probability of the word given by the
document language model.
So you can see in this retrieval
function we actually know the count of the word in
the query.
So the only thing that we don't know is
this document language model.
Therefore, we have converted the
retrieval problem, include the problem of
estimating this document language
model.
So that we can compute the probability
of each query word given by this
document.
And different estimation methods
here would lead to different
ranking functions.
Now this is just like a different ways
to place a document vector in the vector
space would lead to a different
ranking function in the vector
space model.
Here different ways to estimate these
document language model would lead to
a different ranking function for query
likelihood.